Here's everything I made today to make sure we have food to eat.
I started off the day with some protein
scrambled eggs from my backyard chickens
and then had a bowl of the only cereal I would buy
because it's got friendly organic
made with only real ingredients and unrefined sugar.
It's also gluten free with prebiotic fiber from casaba root.
It's so good and I had it with raw milk.
Next I shaped a freshly milled sourdough bowl
that I had started the day before.
After fermenting all night at room temperature,
I did a quick counter, then shaped it into a round
and sewed it up to do its final proof in a flowered banaton.
Later I made my OG banana bread.
It's gluten free free and made with fermented buckwheat.
Fun fact this is one of the first recipes I ever developed.
It took me so many times to get it right and it's honestly so perfect.
You should give it a try too!
The buckwheat ferments for 24 hours on the counter
and the final batter whips up in one bowl in just a few minutes.
Flowed up with healthy fats from pasture raised eggs
and shredded coconut
and tastes delicious with coconut oil or raw butter.
Towards dinner time,
I prep some 100% grass fed beef from my parents farm
by combining 4 pounds of meat with the variety of dried spices, herbs,
salt and pepper, eggs,
raw milk, and shredded cheese.
I bake The meatballs at 4:25 for 20 minutes.
While those baked,
I made some pickled onions and then started on preparing a Greek salad.
I threw a bunch of chopped basil in
and then whisked up a simple salad dressing of pickled onion, vinegar,
olive oil, Dijon,
and salt and pepper. This salad was so fresh and crisp.
Dinner was freshly milled iron cream,
sourdough, and a Greek salad with meatballs on top.